world leaders have condemned russia's
most recent military activity
in and around ukraine the g7 group of
advanced nations says that it's deeply
concerned by what it calls russian
provocations
ukraine accuses moscow of sending
thousands of troops to its eastern
border
and the crimea peninsula kiev and moscow
have traded blame over the worsening
situation in dambass
in this region ukrainian troops have
fought pro-russian separatists since
2014 clashes in the region have become
more frequent and
there are fears that the unresolved
conflict between the two sides
could flare up again
a russian military camp set up suddenly
close to russia's border with ukraine
witnesses have reported seeing rows of
tanks in the area
and artillery being moved by train and
leaders in europe and the us
are trying to find out why russia is not
denying the troop movements but says
it's not threatening anyone
questions are being asked what is it
that the russian federation is doing on
the border with ukraine
the answer is very simple we live there
it is our country some kremlin figures
have gone further
setting out conditions for a possible
russian intervention against its
neighbor
the beginning of military actions is the
beginning of the end of ukraine
the buildup seems to be russia's biggest
along the ukrainian border in seven
years
that was when fighting between
pro-russian separatists and
ukrainian troops first erupted in
ukraine's east
more than fourteen thousand people have
since died in that conflict
which has yet to be resolved
[Music]
ukraine's president volody mirzalenski
recently visited frontline troops
he's called on nato to put his country
on a pathway to join the military bloc
something moscow has called unacceptable
meanwhile washington is sending warships
to the region
and says it's closely watching the
situation
well first let me say we are um
concerned as i've said
uh in the past but we've been of course
watching it over the course of the
weekend
about the increasing aggression of
russian forces on the border secretary
blinken and secretary austin are in
brussels this week
meeting with their nato partners and we
will of course i'm sure this will be a
topic of
discussion the coming week could well
decide whether the tensions in ukraine
escalate further
into the biden administration's first
international crisis
and for more i am joined now by dw
correspondent terry schultz who is
standing by with a view from brussels
terry walk us through efforts to
de-escalate the situation
good morning sarah well i think this
last minute dash by the u.s secretary of
state to brussels especially when the
defense secretary was already scheduled
to be here
underscores just what a worrisome and
delicate situation
this is ukraine has called a meeting of
the nato ukraine commission
so they will be meeting today at nato
headquarters within a couple of hours
and the secretary of state i would
expect will join them so uh certainly
a high-level meetings called at the last
minute
tells all of us that everyone is very
very worried about this situation the g7
and the eu high representative also put
out a statement yesterday
calling on russia to cease provocations
and you know earlier uh germany and
france came under quite a bit of
criticism for saying
that both sides should de-escalate
that's certainly not what we're hearing
now
walk us through what's expected from
this meeting today terry
yes this is uh the the general body that
handles
all nato relations with ukraine i mean
that means cooperative
exercises um training of armed forces
but certainly today called by the
ukrainian government
it's going to focus on this build up of
russian troops
um foreign minister kulepa will also
meet secretary general stoltenberg
and we'll be hearing from them i would
expect that the ukrainian foreign
minister
will reiterate his country's desire for
nato membership to be speeded up
nato has been on a very slow path to
membership now for decades
and at times the ukrainian population
has not wanted to
to move forward on that now the
government is certainly of one mind it
wants
nato to spread its protective umbrella
over ukraine
which of course is problematic in all
kinds of ways because part of that
country
is occupied by some russian forces there
in the east
we're hearing a lot of condemnation a
lot of tough talk terry um
you know we we heard in our piece for
example the press secretary
um at the white house expressing concern
the secretary of state anthony blinken
uh going one step
further warning on sunday that if russia
acts recklessly or aggressively there
will be
costs there will be consequences
what is he talking about what could that
mean
well the fact that he doesn't spell out
the costs and consequences
again makes clear how difficult this
situation is
every single time the alliance does
anything
to reassure ukraine to uh to train
ukrainian forces
russia calls it a provocation and says
this is more justification for building
up
these troops on the border russia
portrays this as a potential effort to
invade russia
so it's a very very fine line and
certainly nato's plan a b
and c is deterrence so when that's not
working they really have to get together
and decide what to do there are
nato forces in the baltic countries and
poland that have been built up since the
2014
uh russian invasion of ukraine nobody
expects to have to use them but that's
that's why they're there just in case
uh i expect that the nato uh secretary
general
will be getting some very pointed
questions today about
exactly what kind of plans could work if
deterrence is not effective
absolutely and terry we know you'll
you'll be monitoring the situation in
brussels today as these diplomatic
efforts
uh really kick into high gear terry
schultz we'll be checking back in with
you
thank you so much for the view from
brussels
you